huawei the world's largest maker of
telecom equipment became a global leader
in designing cutting-edge chips rivaling
those made by samsung apple and nvidia
but ever since the us imposed sanctions
against huawei in 2019 the chinese tech
giant has been losing its foothold in
the global smartphone market
the restrictions that came down on
huawei in 2019 certainly took the
company by surprise the u.s for a long
time saw the company as a national
security threat but it took quite a few
years for washington to kind of really
mobilize itself and take some serious
action against the company a spike in
demand has contributed to the global
chip shortage but ongoing u.s china
political frictions have exacerbated the
situation for huawei so what led the us
to impose restrictions on the chinese
tech giant
first the u.s has long seen huawei as a
national security threat especially as
it was advancing so quickly in 5g
technology this was seen as a problem
among some us policy makers who have
long been concerned that huawei
telecommunications gear can in some way
be intercepted or tapped by the chinese
government huawei has denied this
allegation
two more reasons for the restrictions
allegations of intellectual property
theft and violation of trade sanctions
in 2019 the u.s charged huawei with
attempting to steal trade secrets from
t-mobile and with violating trade
sanctions against iran
the alleged fraudulent financial schemes
used by huawei and its chief financial
officer were not just illegal but
detrimental to the security of the
united states huawei previously denied
all of these allegations but in
september the company's cfo reached a
deal with the us admitting to some
wrongdoing in the iran trade sanctions
case
both cases are still ongoing
later in 2019 the u.s placed huawei on
what's called the entity list banning
u.s companies like google and qualcomm
from working with huawei
then in 2020 the us tightened the terms
of the entity listing twice cutting
huawei off from its own chip
manufacturers and then later blocking
huawei from accessing any chip built
using us technology us technology is so
deeply embedded in this supply chain so
this was a truly destructive measure
that blocked the company from chip
makers not just in the u.s but in taiwan
in europe even in mainland china despite
the restrictions any company that wants
to sell to huawei can apply for a
license from the us government but these
are often difficult to get for example
qualcomm is able to sell 4g chip
technology to huawei other companies are
selling more rudimentary chips to huawei
and you can see that that's really an
offshoot of this underlying desire and
policy circles in washington to reign in
huawei's 5g technology without totally
sort of choking off the company from any
components whatsoever
since september 2020 huawei has been
relying on its stockpile of chips but
its supply is now running low huawei is
investing in domestic chip makers but it
could still take them years to catch up
to us technology huawei released a new
phone in july but without high-tech
chips it can't connect to 5g networks
and analysts say it will struggle to
compete globally in september huawei
deputy chairman eric shu said the
company's smartphone revenue will drop
by up to 40 billion dollars this year
and so far there haven't been any signs
from washington that the us will loosen
these restrictions you're seeing huawei
pull back on 5g you're seeing huawei
lose out on 5g contracts you're seeing
its 5g phone sales totally collapsed and
in many ways this was the goal of some
of the sanctions
[Music]